listen man I got a lot of questions
um uh I know you love TV so I'm just
going to throw out there uh what's the
thing right now that you can't live
without on television
okay yeah we're on the same page and
door is the best thing on TV it's the
best Star Wars series there has been I'm
obsessed with it uh I I watch each
episode I'm like I cannot believe how
good this show is and how much it
captures the spirit of Star Wars without
featuring any iconic Star Wars
characters I've been saying to everyone
because I I do think gandor is the best
thing on television that it is even if
you took the Star Wars out of it it
would be the best show on television it
just happens to it just happens to have
Star Wars yes the the quiet I nothing
prepared me for the uh the high quality
of the show I mean I I love Mandalorian
and
um and and the other Star Wars shows but
this is just this is next level good I
completely agree and by the way I'm sure
it's the same with you when they
announced Endor
um I'm like yeah okay
this might be okay like I don't know if
I care and now I'm like check it out
yeah now I'm like this is the [ __ ]
best thing on TV
but yeah and I'm so happy because
usually a lot of these series there's
like six or eight episodes this one I
think there's like 12 or something in
the first season so it's like it feels
long like it feels generous like we're
getting a lot of time with it and
they're already doing a second season so
yeah obsessed yeah we're on the same
page okay so in an emergency
um something happens in your house I
don't know where you live what's the
Smurfs item that you are grabbing to
save uh it's the green surprise bag
Smurf that kid got me at Christmas it's
extremely rare it's worth a lot of money
and uh it was a just a very special gift
uh and I think that would be the first
one that I grabbed but let's be clear I
would take as much as I could right of
course
um listen you do you have done a lot you
have sat where I'm sitting many times
how weird is it for you to be on where
you are right now and like doing hours
of press
um I'm just I'm just curious what it's
like
weird so incredibly weird I'm glad you
asked that
um it's it's it's a bit of a mind you
know what uh I'm much more comfortable
in your we're sitting where you're
sitting asking the questions
um and sort of being in control this is
New Territory for me yeah um did they
make you do media training did you want
to
I didn't do media training
um it crossed my mind but you know at
the same time I did some press when the
book came out so I had some experience
talking about this uh subject matter
um and also my concern about like media
training is I don't want to get inside
my head too much I don't want to have
like rehearsed sound bites I I want to
come to this as naturally as possible
because as someone who interviews people
for a living those to me are the best
interviews you can tell when someone is
coming off a little too polished a
little too rehearsed uh and I didn't
want to bring that energy to this you
you know also what it's like when you
ask a question and you're getting a
completely different answer you're like
what the what just happened right yeah
you know um so you obviously um wrote
the book did you ever at any point did
your whole life story did you at any
point think about writing of the first
draft of the script or did you say like
I I don't want to do that now it crossed
my mind like we all options were
considered and and absolutely I I I
thought about it and these were
conversations that I had with my
creative Partners on this with Jim
Parsons and Michael Showalter and I
think we all agreed at the end of the
day that we were excited to see what uh
new writers could bring to this story
and you know and make it cinematic
um and I'm so glad that we did but I
will say that I was very involved in the
process every step of the way uh it was
a very collaborative process so it's not
like I just you know washed my hands of
it after I optioned the book and walked
away and let other people make the movie
I I was very Hands-On
um and uh and Michael Showalter uh made
it a really safe collaborative
environment one of the things that I
love about the film is that it's just an
honest relationship it's it's an honest
story and it's never hollywoodizing
anything
um can you sort of talk about the fact
that they they you know it
um I guess that aspect of it that it's
not going for the big third Act
craziness or whatever
yeah well I mean it's being true to the
book which I think is important and
something that I stressed from the
beginning you know there were certain
aspects of the book like the DNA of the
book that I wanted the movie to capture
and and we everybody was sort of on the
same page and one of those things is
relationships are messy people are
imperfect and uh
there was there's no value in you know
sort of softening those hard edges or in
sugarcoating aspects of that because
that's reality and I think it it what
it's what makes the book and the movie
ultimately relatable I know you were on
set basically every day I can't imagine
what it's like to sit there and watch
people like your life right there in
front of you so can you sort of talk
about uh that aspect of it well there
were moments that were absolutely
surreal especially you know there were
some sequences that were very close to
uh real life including the deck scene
towards the end of the movie really
captured the spirit of how that
experience was for the most part though
it wasn't hard uh in the way I think
maybe a lot of people think like I never
felt like I was watching my life being
replayed in front of my eyes I knew we
were making a movie I knew this wasn't a
documentary and I also knew that these
incredible actors were going to be
bringing their own uh putting their own
spin on these roles and making them
their own so I never thought like Jim
was like mimicking me or impersonating
me and the same thing with Ben and kid
they were creating almost these these
new people
um that were based on real people talk a
little about the title spoiler alert uh
I it's a great title and I'm just
curious uh with the book obviously uh
how did you decide on it and also
um was it always going to be the title
for the movie so the the title of the
book came about halfway through writing
the book and it it hit me like the best
kind of light bulb going off in my brain
uh it just plays on a number of levels
wanna is uh that it's cheeky you know
it's sort of silly and sarcastic which
is very much the spirit of the book and
was the spirit of my relationship is n
is my sense of humor but also spoilers
that's my business that's my I built my
career career on spoilers and it just
felt very on brand to you know find a
way to work that into the title was it
always going to be the title of the
movie
yeah it was I um there was never any
question about uh changing the title
although the title of the movie is just
spoiler alert where the you know it's uh
it it leaves off a couple of keywords
although I think most people are able to
do the math on that note I'm just going
to say congrats on the movie and I'm
glad we both love Andor as much as we do
oh thank you so much